well traveling for treatment even in the
midst of the coronavirus
a young las vegas girl with a rare
disease is continuing to get
life-changing medical help and it's all
thanks to a local charity
eight news now reporter orko mana has
our story
and i feel like dancing is just for me
madeleine forrester is just like any 11
year old girl
can it be called the savage dance she's
obsessed with tick-tock dances and she's
an avid cheerleader but you'll notice
she's in a wheelchair i have spinal
muscular atrophy
which is holds me back from doing
walking jumping and running mandolin has
been fighting this disease since she was
18 months old
she now travels to the children's
hospital of colorado for spinal
injections which slow the progression
and help build muscle
it's all thanks to miracle flights a las
vegas-based charity that helps those
with complex conditions pay for airfare
to get the medical care they need
it is terminal madeleine's mom christina
tells me she
is worried about kovit 19 because sma
makes madeleine immunocompromised
it's very scary in terms of having to
travel such a long distance or through
airports
everywhere everybody's been or touched
if she does get this virus that
you know it might be fatal for her as
well but the treatments are time
sensitive
she does need it every four months
miracle flight says they're doing
everything they can to keep people safe
by providing them with masks and
coordinating ground transportation to
appointments
uh our goal is to not only ease the
financial burden that these families
face
but also the stress that comes with
having to fly
during the pandemic i got a whole dream
ahead of me
madeleine taking this all in stride
knowing she's getting the best help
there is
i'm glad i can do some stuff
and what other kids can do orco mana 8
news now
well madeline will head out on her sixth
miracle flight to colorado
tomorrow and it just so happens to be
national aviation day brian she looks
like quite the fighter
what a strong young lady keep dancing
madeline